there's a whole year to go before this
book hits the shelves but
one thing is certain it's going to hit
the shelves in a very
important royal year not least because
it is the queen's platinum jubilee
celebrations
those celebrations take place in june
they will mark the queen's 70th year on
the throne
but they will span the entire year this
is really the year
that the queen wants to define her range
he wants to move on from the travels of
the past
and make it very clear that the house of
windsor
is secure that the succession is secure
and this is really the cherry
on the cake for what has been a
remarkable reign so it's going to be a
busy royal year
an eventful royal year and yet what do
we see
well by the sounds of things the sussex
is once again
dominating royal headlines that's not
the year
that the queen or the palace had been
anticipating
well i certainly think on this side of
the pond in the uk
a lot of people find harry's behavior
hypocritical i mean
let's not forget the sussex said they
wanted to leave the uk to avoid
the intrusion of the british media to
have a quiet life where they could raise
archie of course they've now got two
children
away from the media spotlight and yet
everything we see them doing
isn't just a very commercial enterprise
it's a very
public enterprise too well i think a lot
of people wondering why there is such
impatience on harry's heart the oprah
interview came at a time when his
grandfather wasn't very well the timing
felt
very unfortunate over that interview and
now again we're seeing
the potential for real clashes here
between what the royals are doing
and what the couples are doing and
people are saying that makes harry
appear
tone deaf and out of touch so why the
hurry
well clearly he wants to tell his
version of the story
he wants to tell his truth but i do
think underlying all of this
is the very simple matter of making
money
the reason that the sussex is left was
not just for independence from the royal
family
they wanted financial freedom as well
well they've made a fortune now
more than enough to retire them for the
rest of their lives but a lot of people
are saying
at what cost just how much are they
cashing in on their royal connections
and i think so harry
that is a real problem well the press
release that we received said
that proceeds from the book are going to
be going to charity well that's
all very well and good and we know that
harry and megan are both great
philanthropists
but that doesn't quite address the
matter of a very meaty
20 million dollar advance so i suspect
i think most people's reading of this is
that harry is going to pocket
the pretty hefty advance that's going to
retire him for the rest of his life
and some you know we've got a whole year
to go before this book actually hits the
shelves and i'm sure there will be a lot
of speculation is harry going to reveal
who the alleged royal racist is what's
he going to say about his early
childhood
will we hear him talk or write in more
detail about the
impact of losing his mother and what
really happened in those days
after he found out that she'd been
killed in a car crash in paris
there are still many parts of harry's
life particularly his younger life
that have yet to be explored and he has
promised us a null holds no-holds-barred
autobiography a memoir in which he is
able to be wholly truthful
about his life a memoir that will surely
have the royals
very nervous very apprehensive about
exactly what's to come
i think inevitably there is going to be
a huge
curiosity factor in this and for the
moment
most of what harry and megan say carries
a high currency
i think the real question is how
sustainable is that how much new
information are we going to hear and how
many more bombshells
can harry actually drop on the royal
[Music]
family
you